hi, I'm A.P.
and I'm Miss Germany 24.
Today I'm clearing up clichés.
How important is appearance in the Miss Germany election?
Miss Germany is no longer a beauty pageant.
the concept has changed.
it's about women who want to take responsibility.
it's about inner beauty.
What do you have to be able to do to become Miss Germany?
1 have a great topic that you want to convey to the outside world.
what is your topic?
My topic is,
that young women with a migration background
would like to encourage
to become the best version of yourself.
Is a pageant a form of self-expression?
you have to be able to stand in front of the camera
and can present,
When you want to carry a mission to the outside world.
how do you deal with criticism in a person?
if it is a constructive criticism,
then uh,
I'm happy about it and I'm happy to answer them.
ifs but
Nonsense, then uh,
I don't have time for it.
what is the profit on the show?
you can win 25,000 euros.
what obligations do you have with the title
Miss Germany?
I will now
Have 1 management by my side for 1 year
and we will build a strategy together
and see what we do for great projects
in the direction of my mission.
it will be towards education architecture,
Events for young women.